c'est un grand un grand plaisir quand
honneur quand on vous en hommage quant
aux mages à votre travail parce que bon
j'ai c'est sûr que j'ai j'ai eu dans ma
carrière pas mal de dommages mais à des
hommages qui sont beaucoup plus chers à
mon coeur que d'autres et cet hommage du
caribéen film international festival
film festival ici à los angeles bon ben
ça fait partie de ces images qui me sont
très chers que j'apprécie parce que
s'ils se sentir honoré par le sien puis
je sais la caraïbe c'est aux états unis
et nous pour les artistes que nous
sommes c'est très important d'être
reconnu par les siens
même si on reçoit dix mille pris
ailleurs même si mais ne pas recevoir
des prix ne pas recevoir des honneurs de
son propre pays
c'est vrai que c'est
c'est pas ça fait mal quoi et on en
attend ça on attend que ça arrive et
quand ça arrive on est très content
puisqu'on sait que c'est tout un pays si
votre pays qui voient connaît le travail
que vous avez fait et aussi l'hommage
que vous lui faites en créant et ce
travail étant honoré on honore en même
temps votre pays